oh boy am I excited world eggs man of
Madonn baby when you're watching this
video I will be on honeymoon
what a great honeymoon gift thank you
very much I get to play this before
everyone else this is from the creators
of until dawn which is an amazing game I
love that game so much I've been waiting
for them to do something else and here
it is everyone I pray a new series man
of medina smash like subscribe if you're
excited we're at a hundred million
hopefully while this goes up three two
one let's go and I forgot it's a band I
game I have to sell my soul just kidding
they are nice to me oh yeah you can play
this with people we're playing it yay
here we go man of Madden mad at me - hey
what is this new story please new slot
please Fioretti a trickle kind okay so
the game should be roughly a couple
hours like five hours I think four to
five hours and the goal is
to keep all the characters alive which
is not gonna happen if you're watching
this playthrough just letting you know
now
[Music]
oh my god I thought they were gonna play
Maya he for a second my okay a bunch of
graves on a boat
Oh are we in decide them is that how we
got in the boat I shouldn't be making
guesses even though we're in China I did
say something
are those Madeline's epic
alrighty buster we better mosey on back
to the ship
yeah buster whoa stop the presses what
looks like Oh Charlie charmings got a
little business to attend to
okay I played enough Legend of Zelda to
no oh god no poor DOMA yo sure can I
fight hey give me a quarter fight you
have to finally gonna find out my future
oh sorry my mind so it's in no way let's
have it
what's in store for me pop post-world
War three Jase yep hey yo even MA oh oh
do I tell me about my son will I be rich
will I be rich so when am I gonna hit
the jackpot
you know all that glitz and glamor names
these games almost look so again
come on glitz and glamour glitz and
glamour ooh
[Music]
dragon Tyler bamboo town no one's
hitting bamboo tile come on now okay
fine we'll hit bamboo town Kanye jump I
look at the tile wall new kashama Oh
what do I see press and hold to pick up
objects okay and then I used to examine
oh he let it go cuz I let go of the
mouse
this game is very attractive it's an
element I hit the jackpot
looks like a fish damn I'm gonna be rich
damn this game looks good that's high
fool your fortune light songs yeah
I sure don't we like sweet okay
doom wait what I love doing this is a
great game hey what does that mean what
the hell man hey don't it don't shoot
the messenger
hey bud let me get it go at it oh yeah I
think you got the stuff you know beanie
the polio Dada go home I sure okay she's
very sinister sure let me another
quarter gonna start a tab alright I'm
ready for this
that's so cute ah what all right bring
it huh yeah in the foot
get him in the foot you like that I can
do more yeah doesn't matter where I hit
it
no it doesn't matter as long as this in
this circle D good thing I was ready red
deeds okay yeah I am fighting woman yeah
screw your foot that's surely has to
hurt a lot if you get hit by that no I
hit a sorry my bad gamers I win
she's your new Noir have a nice day ah
all right I will accept this night dummy
hey Chuck we better get back to the ship
we don't want to get stranded come on
man just let me ask another quick
let's grab some melons let's get on back
that is so cozy though man I want to go
to China that's awesome I can quite
dummies
also they're bringing back like
important people that died in the war
could that be it
help history lessons
[Music]
YouTube shipping their hundred million
award
damn I'm the first one that gets to play
this it just hit me so cool
we're definitely opening this
[Music]
in it
hey where's my
where's my quarter oh my God he's
actually complain
what their sheet background Oh
my medical
these men appear to be drunk off their
rear end
sorry I hope this isn't cut anything but
I kind of want to turn on subtitles in
case you guys can't hear us
I have to click something to save it or
can I just go back I was always a
question in the menu do you want to say
yes okay my apology for 50 cents
really how much was 50 cents back then
back in my day
[Music]
I'm googling in Turkey RIA
that's fine they are definitely coming
back alive Chinese one dollar is twelve
bucks okay
so $6 epic
ooh I like the sound of that
potential meme added right there
still no know what year it is and this
is where we get to walk damn this game
looks good well done
yeah
oh you got your 50 cents bro epic I
thank the game wants us to get the key
let's get it gamers oh man all right
we're investigating it looks like I need
to cut my nails that's kind of gross but
fine what about the money bro yeah all
right we can keep examining him but
doesn't look like there's anything so
back please this is so cool I love this
the background looks so realistic
it's like we're playing a movie okay can
I go here no probably not well now we
have the key so that means we can leave
that almost rhyme that's so cool stay
tuned for more epic commentary
damn alright the game wants me to go
here but I'm always like well if they
want me to go there then maybe I should
check out here for no reason then waste
everyone's time okay sorry just making
sure
all right here we go this is so cool the
textures on the walls look so real and I
don't even know why I'm whispering
howdy charlie how's your time off just
get me out of here already
there's a dead guy in the locker health
going on up there
I heard aircraft and gunfire me too and
there was a corpse what's in the sick
bay something's wrong
let's get out of here
I like this guy this guy things like a
champ hey what's going on
it smells like farting here more epic
commentary just keep watching in that
private Charles Anderson on leave from
duty did display intoxication in a
manner not becoming of a member of the
US Army private Anderson was engaging
with another solider in their drunken
argument well we know this it is the
opinion of the arresting officer that
this would lead to a public brawl and
steps were taken to ensure that both men
were returned to ship so this is our
file huh very well so we weren't
supposed to be on the ship question mark
more dumb questions coming right up guys
just keep watching
all right I don't think there's anything
else to see in here shiny object on wall
I will discover you yeah what are you
doing here
that's my whatsapp everyone no need to
check your phone
that's all me hopefully there won't be
any more what's happening in here
okay
here we go sorry about that bruh
we'll be fine as long as we stick
together oh god yes press s in time with
a heartbeat okay
oh the he could die here for sure okay
all right this is just like real life oh
my god boom
dundun
what a dummy dumb how long
easy looks like you're live buddy boy
that's his nickname nine buddy boy what
a great name
hey don't smart no sore on my watch
hello Georgie believe us me man who's
that ah don't do that
what was what the kid what kid oh my god
Oh shiny shiny
got to investigate the shiny stuff bruh
you just gotta look at it looks like
we're locked in - hey Charlie help -
boys yeah you said it
fubar in that song freaked up beyond all
recognition
damn bruh it's the Chinese
I'm gonna go ahead and say if the
Chinese I'm going a little limb here and
I'm gonna say it's China the Chinese
maybe we should have investigated more
about that I I kind of want to keep the
flow going go dad another stick who's
the lucky winner chicken dinner
let's check them
damnit Buckley Oh buster I saw him in
the mess hall he was fit as a fiddle
[ __ ] look at Buckley
it's the rigor mortis stiff as a fiddle
my god this is so dope look at this
love the camera angles
I don't know if I want to walk faster I
can walk down here let's go to hold
three let's just follow him for now is
it just me or are you getting a real
strange feeling right now
no why like a guy who likes to talk
about his feelings ha you look like a
mess on wheels children ain't the only
one great
good company hey Chuck you see that kid
over there
no the kid feeling all right yeah there
was definitely child we need to kick him
I played enough minecraft to know how to
deal with it
oh that's normal whoo that's the
position I want to die in just like that
Charlie
get over here
ah
that people be like mortgage mom
thumbnail get it oh we get to shoot epic
[Music]
damn he looks psycho well we don't even
know these twos relationship we don't
know anything all right I'm ready
I got reflexes something's about to
happen in three all right that child
needs to go I'm done child needs to pie
fight
who said gas is that dang gas
Kamiya what were they sedating before
haha Wow oh god no charlie
why show job
oh yeah spraying spraying come on yeah
you got a spray
maybe I mean I know I said it but I
didn't think he would do it so oh no
what I do
no did we just die I shouldn't have
sprayed him
or did we die I'm so confused Mayday
is anyone there hello can anyone help
there hear me this is our new character
[Music]
yeah that has too many lanes
look at this dude
Tydeus motocross
Oh am i controlling anything
he did
[Music]
damn
what
my god what an intra Oh
[Music]
won't you spare me over till like this
okay all right
intro
what
that's so cool
well what is
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a man of Madonna
supermassive games
that's what they're called how could I
forget happy
[Music]
unreal
here we go gamers oh man
well is he the one that breaks the
fourth wall yet welcome thank you to my
repulsive
[Music]
well well well what do we have here
because until dawn had these aspect of
the game where you would they did like a
psychoanalysis is that it
I don't remember I am the curator the
curator of stories and has the seller is
a lock inque greed and beauty life and
death okay stories such as this one
I'm here to record the story you choose
to tell oh you see this tale is only
part written oh and the choices you make
will complete it I like Nate Erman
rather the lives of those with whom you
are interfering continue to flourish or
whether they are flip flops snuffed out
or then almost got it
you see we each make decisions according
to our own moral compass that's true and
we have to live with those decisions or
die by them but you shouldn't fear death
it is after all
oh no never table and does the tax one
pays for having lived and it comes
eventually to everybody all right yeah
none of us want for it to come too soon
do don't look at me like that as in life
the actions you take matter the choices
you make will affect us
I'll be keeping a close eye on your
progress it's not my place to interfere
but I might be persuaded to offer the
occasional hint please do anything for
free oh there are pictures in this world
that can show you some possible futures
if you can find them and study them they
may just help you to make better
decision
so paintings will show the future got it
I say decisions that result in the
outcomes you would prefer but how does
he know which one I prefer for the
moment we'll talk again soon we'll have
the opportunity to account for all the
actions that you've taken now god he's
gonna scold me for doing badness yeah
it's like I'm I'm seeing what the
comments are gonna be like even before I
made the bad choice what'd I tell you
guys come on
big brain such a big large brain my god
okay this is nice less dramatic Duke
Madonn is that what I said no sorry
I have lights on my face okay those are
nice feet oh it's a guy I'm married it
doesn't matter I'm not even a feet guy
I swear Brad Duke of Milan french
polynesia and his name is Brad that's
funny
Brad motivate Alex Brad's brother
Julie's boyfriend Ian is a cure enough
no now we can always call for backup
Road can we look I've never been down
there before down the water diving maybe
you could show me how the pros do it are
you serious yeah I mean are you serious
who came out here without taking any
lessons kind of yeah yeah I was insecure
it's to level with him you know it's
embarrassing taking them by yourself
it's embarrassing you came all the way
out here expecting me to hold your hand
oh my god what a babe blip blop relax
dude careful that dive cam is like super
explode be cool what Julie and Conrad
are they must be here for a purpose safe
super [ __ ] loaded so so don't sweat
the little stuff man it's not cool don't
make me regret letting you tag along
okay that's why he's pissed
um I can't okay
well go knives you know I'm not like the
best around new people
whatever shut up you gotta loosen up
come on just say yeah to everything on
this trip
wait trust me I want you to have a good
time okay well what if somebody asked me
to do something stupid like run around
naked or something or Ackley just go
with it
all right amigo Calvary is almost here
whoo sorry I'm a little snappy yeah
you're very snappy when you medical
school would be stressful you know
total shocker and man it's like Disney
Julia it's been rough just me uh
okay now we hit them back it's been like
two weeks yeah huh
yep right on cue Conrad is right I have
enough beer ah I guess I keep these in
an undisclosed location yeah
damn everything it's so cool so what can
I get you and put on something yeah what
it's uh kind of a big thing I'm trying
to make a decision about what is out
finishing med school no but it's just
kind of a big life choice you know he's
got a poop I don't know what's the right
thing to do I don't know what to tell
this guy I don't know give it some
thought you sure you're ready give it
some thought consider all the
permutations
that's beautiful my god hey Julia no
sorry Julia you're gonna have to go
Julia I'm telling it what that's him I
recognize him
right that's an actor right they're all
actors Julia's gonna dance sorry you
must gonna Donny this is Alex hey what's
up man Conrad I swear I recognize him
watch it says Ladykiller right here good
to finally meet you kyrat this is Brad
by the way I'm a little bro hey Bradley
feel like I already know you have heard
so much about you yeah
likewise ooh awkward hey man want a
crack : with me every second with the
boys that guy that plays in the robot
series I'm in watch it sorry relax yeah
cool yeah cool we just met so tight I
love beer how old is he supposed to be
he got really famous after he did now
until dawn forgot his name that he's a
great actor right on radical I like the
cut of your ship it's Jim good jab ha ha
you ever do any diving before no no
actually never done it before
water virgin nice Hey we're gonna pop
your cherry together mmm
[Music]
you gotta be on there's the old crest
bucket skipper hangout place oh god I'm
scared already
impatient yet I see that I'd invite you
to make yourselves at home
but why does everyone have an attitude
so is everybody on board and ready to go
there must be a reason
they definitely do not remove their
drinks on the boat from the shore the
hey who do dude I'm all right you know
what never mind this is cool this is
very cool
Helen's are beautiful
okay way to help her that's it get it
all out yeah I gets crazy seasick - when
I go light down
yeah you know maybe I should yeah little
boy
so we must be looking for something over
here yeah definitely that's pretty far
out of the way I'm just thinking about
backup targets in case we don't find
anything on the dive cam listen to be
honest I've never heard of this direct
you're looking for usually these things
are crawling with divert we're looking
for that yeah this is different I'm just
saying if it gets too late I know some
nice places where you can just take you
know a nice dive uh Optimus I did his
homework if he says the wrecks here it's
here okay look you're the client I'm
just saying we don't have unlimited
daylight I'm gonna go help Conrad and
jewel you with the camera what you got
feast your eyes on this mmm Wow brats
calculations were right on the money
always bright on bright kids a whiz we
should thank him what we found a plane
yeah that looks like world war two we
are ready to dive technically we should
call this into port off the roaring as
an unreported wreck
well technically are you sure you don't
want to do this the right way
ah who cares look for all anyone knows
we were just diving and then all right
right so who cares the right way come on
what is this kindergarten I had to bring
it up if we just go down and take a look
who's gonna know fine as long as you're
quick don't touch anything we're
definitely gonna touch stuff I can't
wait to be the first one down there can
you imagine I'm touched you lay your
gonna touching and you're gonna die
sorry I'm just saying jewel is gonna I'm
just saying we should be ready to get
you guys in the water in a few I'll set
up the tanks the boys will do the final
checks take a look at the camera see if
you can find anything useful right oh
I'm sorry Julia I take back everything
you should check on your bro well give
her a chance
just don't smile we should be all good
all right checking on my bro get the
plate chicken on my bro hey hey hey I
don't how do I am I not supposed to go
to here yeah
he doesn't really want to walk come on
bro no but I definitely did not press
back there we go
I got stuck for some reason it's doing
it again I swear I'm trying here we go
[Music]
most likely playing like on newer
versions sometimes is a little wonky I
did see something shiny upstairs as well
he really doesn't want to walk does he
is it the mouse time missus in bra you
got a walk bra bra
maybe I check I jiggle my way there
oh yeah oh and jiggling what's up you do
it sorry that brewski got the better of
me don't worry all part of the adventure
got to keep it up sorry for putting a
damper on things
no worries dude take more than that just
to screw up the trip let's get some rest
come back when you're feeling better you
can't really be mad at someone for being
seasick come on relationship updated oh
man creeper in the toilet oh man this is
a massive boat by the way oh yeah yeah
the pictures we can see the future
oh god it's not a storm I I swear I
cannot move
what was that premonition I'll mock high
and dry
[Music]
sorry I'll never do that again oh I'm
getting the hang of the controls one
moment at a time seems to work yeah
maybe not
okay here we go rules for diving always
use your body system epic Felicia
Felicia taught to battle a bit a little
bit better I wanted to read it but okay
I forgot I had to hold it down sorry
maybe there's something in the back my
curiosity is itching too much
brown brown 5/8 shorter than me okay
nice Comic Sans always a nice touch I
respect it
and then I did see something yeah we're
gonna talk to her right okay I'm
pressing a and he goes present w oh ah
man no you know we have rules out here
for a reason
you guys got to respect that
alright well we paid a lot less we paid
a lot of money for this particular dive
in this particular spot every time I
take a group of you people out it's the
same thing hey what do you mean no
regard for anyone elses customs these
rules are all pretty basic stuff how
much experience do you have with these
kind of dives you'd have to know the
rules no that's not an amount enough to
know the rule I don't think you do
clearly we don't know the rules this
could be a war grave disturbing it would
be illegal and immoral I'm shaking who's
gotta know you see anyone else out here
who's gonna know we logged our route at
the harbor if someone sees it's been
disturbed ain't gonna be hard to put two
and two together especially if some
little souvenirs show up online you know
what I can't stop you just respect the
rules down there don't do anything
stupid that'll get my ass in trouble
swore I want to swim I can't wait to
swim
alright gamers let's go so this is the
rebreather way cooler than a regular
scuba setup it takes all that co2 that
you'd normally just exhale into the
water and instead it gets totally reused
tonio reduces decompression time on your
way up stay video damn that's cool okay
Oh to check done it's gonna break and
she's gonna die
I'm calling I'm just calling it you
gotta check your o2 first yeah check
your OT beaver uh thanks for setting me
straight oh hey guys what Jesus why are
you so loud I almost completely forgot
when I was looking at the dive cam I saw
this huge hole in tail Kamui that's your
way into the plane oh nice work man
thanks Conrad damn brah hey you little
clown fishes I'm gonna go see what Bliss
is up to behave Connie why would bring a
knife too plain why okay what is that is
that a harpoon isn't it and that's a
camera I will take the heart
if we're already brought a knife then I
got the bang stick kid haha good to go
you ever have to use one on a shire
remember the rules
please wait sorry what
maybe we can fire it up again tonight
for our private post Dyer special are
you gonna bring your bang stick that
front cabin is gonna pop its portholes
she gets the camera no we get both
anyway okay let's go diving gamers
I mean that is pretty cool yeah let's go
banks take time yeah more or less we can
talk what mochi by Lee by Steven plus is
so tight chefs like we're going to
ransack the plane well a souvenir would
be cool but it's not like one tiny
little thing would hurt anybody I won't
tell if you all
rule one apart some never do what you're
not allowed to do but she never break
any rules that's gotta be it
if it says don't open it then just don't
open it yeah it's pretty intact - this
is a [ __ ] remarkable fine for let's
swim around a little and find a way in
howdy captain you fancy a pint with your
second-in-command
you are not my second-in-command third
or no fresh into your cabin we'll still
I know your well-paying dashingly
handsome seafaring client it's
requesting the pleasure of your company
over a frosty amber liquid all right oh
yeah the ladies are cool oh yeah why not
sure why not
doesn't really fit our characters but
you know I wonder loosen up a bit
that'd be reason can massive dude
pretty nice ride you got here where'd
you get the cash that is a very rude
question you know it's not polite to ask
a lady about her money fair enough I was
just thinking about buying a boat myself
and I thought maybe you'd like to point
me in the right direction that's not
your question though was it I'm not a be
my singular pleasure to help you part
with your money
oh god you know what I better spend some
time keeping the Duke of Milan shipshape
aye aye
no no she clicked the iPad what was I
doing
yeah Turner weather looks clear except
that eight where it's gonna freakin
thunder she doesn't seem bothered at all
written over that time right now do me
okay that looks clear it wanted to leave
here sorry it's a shame I can't can't
move yeah thank you game okay here we go
I'm trying to use the mouse now I don't
know if it out beautiful
should we check on the guy how's it
going knocked out by cold frosty man I
feel like such a wimp
hey it's your vacation you're allowed to
overdo it I am officially starting a
temperance Club party of one lifetime
membership hope the lovebirds are having
the time of their lives down there yeah
I know what they're doing doing down
there
attitude matters twenty meters down Alex
plays the goof but he was pretty serious
about acing his diving certification are
you close with your brother
don't have my whole life Julia's got
Alex wrapped around her little finger
I knew it that actually app check you
later
freakin Julian
oh so this is our room yeah painting yes
let's check it out
man the verb is sink a gun another
person keep these around I don't know
that is a strange thing to ask no I'm
trying to go in here now he's in there
okay only we can just walk in here ooh
which we can gamers all right got a hold
down here there we go
shroud and of innocence is that a
reference I'm not entirely sure why I
just did that all right
can't find anything else be on my way
now gamers
literally looked at the photo
we pick up poop okay how's it hanging
we're in a boat I'm not hanging you look
like you're taking full advantage of
your relaxation time I'm a man of many
talents I like how serious she got when
she has to think
so are you beached like a whale hey I
just thought my spend all my time down
in the dark when I already like what I
see up top brah
I have to keep track of the dive but I'd
be happy to continue this conversation
later hey that's too forward if you my
full attention just chatting up you and
I in the old conversational intercourse
yeah I got an achievement for that kind
of frosting
amber eloquent very nice oh we're gonna
see the storm man it's coming
I can move but not much beep beep beep
beep beep
drip drop drip drop wait pop beep-bop
jump-scare No
oh it's a good way to jump ski we're
looking forward somewhere blitt up sea
creatures they're real they're called
fishes also oh can we monitor them this
is live that is not your everyday wreck
I hope those clowns don't get why that's
a beautiful shot look at this look at
this game
look at his dude I don't really know
what else we can do
weather looks clear oh really she's
never said that you could also just look
at it looks clear ah say it again just
for fun
please Oh it automatically did oh man
what's that about fishing boat from the
looks of it perhaps should we handle
this shoot we are not doing anything I'm
the captain so you'd be quiet and let me
handle it you got that this is not gonna
be good
these are not a fishing bug
oh man hey get out of here
what do you think you're doing yeah what
are they doing
[Music]
hey we got damage here you see this look
at our boat we can take care of this man
it's not a problem what do you think
like 10 bucks cover it 10 bucks
oh whoops my bad let's make it 20 whoo
well shoot you you think it's more like
30 I can do 30 this guy is asking to get
his ass be guys drive a hard bargain but
I'm with you here just throwing the
whole pot
[Music]
why don't pick a fight when you're out
on a bone that's the number one rule of
boats after don't sink your boat don't
fall in the water and don't poop from
your boat technically that's fine I
think boob jokes feelings yeah that's
good that's really good
ow
Conrad said one of the pictures showed
an opening here we go I'm excited but
turret we can get him through there
yes would that look sharp careful oh god
Julian oh she's gonna die hey I hit a
what'd I say
Oh sharks are coming Oh careful three
dangerous I swear I hit a oh maybe I did
ease first
I definitely dinner I panicked then I
hit another button we're gonna just take
a second to say holy [ __ ] Alex oh we did
it
I mean can you believe it
yeah told you Jill is gonna die all
right well at least you won't die here
then right or am i swimming I can't see
oh here we go damn this is so cool
Julia leave it you'd have to take your
gear off together they're not worth it
that pint is pretty tight
what if you get stuck without your
rebreather maybe it is kind of dangerous
yeah don't do it the first run like come
on
maybe it is a little dangerous shark is
definitely gonna that's a boning bullet
holes all down the fuselage Brad's gonna
flip when he sees this Brad be like
backflips epicly later'd
God diving making me anxious I don't
like this
good god is he alive
oh my god he's dead oh yeah he's Hawking
something flip-flop that's mine blip
blop is it a girl is it a plane
I'm shaking it but it doesn't shake
anything wow what the hell happened here
I think the plane my seniors they knew
they were goners let's go further
you hear that let's check it out alright
so what is this Jason it's scared of
anything how did I work exactly oh we
had a gun what
I'm trying I hate eels I think I wet my
wetsuit ah what does that mean what does
that mean pilot and co-pilot gotta be
plane crash not high on my list of ways
to perish
you're gonna eaten by sharks you know
that right just so we're clear you're
gonna be happy with that
all right we're going in but where do we
look
easy how this that's been down here a
long time
yeah ya know shake it out all right time
to go right this is hanging out back
there all right dude check it out
they reconfigure the bomb wrap to hold
lifeboats interesting
and they still draft u-boats is missing
I think they were using it let's see
what else we can find
I like how he brought a tripod let's see
what else we find even though we already
kind of found everything awkward I think
next episode I'll play this with a
controller instead because I think it
will work better like I hit any other
thing and she just kind of stops [ __ ]
yeah I'm just gonna go for it
Oh
[Music]
No
okay it's a game you kind of have some
fun but how are you gonna get that back
on
Oh
[Music]
dr. Pisces oh I did it oh my god
you did something stupid down here
that's it one chance you get that I mean
it seems like two chances but hello I'm
fine see no problemo
that's Italian for not oh no problem
searching a progress Claire yes this is
it was a rescue plan launched from a US
base come on Kowalski progress report
[Applause]
also that's what costs the thing - oh
man it's a TIE fighter from Star Wars
you know I told you I told you gamers oh
God Alex Alex it's a great week shark
not interested in us let's go okay cool
[Music]
all right now don't film their feet oh
god I don't like this don't hold on oh
no no no no no no he's gonna propose
yeah he's gonna propose oh my god what
are you doing why are you fidgeting
propose I don't know why yesterday I
wanted to bring something up with you
but it's it's not the best time
oh you had something to raise with me
did you
it doesn't matter let's get back up what
name geez Alex you're more of a wreck
than that plane that just literally fell
apart on top of that mmm-hmm give me a
break okay bruh we've really got to get
up top flip this is Julia we're coming
back up alright
[Music]
probably nothing out of the ordinary
wait Julia we got a decompress here oh
there we we have to decompress
that's why she's getting sick later yeah
okay so we follow the painting thing
otherwise to get that it's sickness
right don't be fine it's not like their
boat is exploding just a few more
seconds okay oh okay we are gonna and
first episode there gamers thank you so
much for letting me play this early this
is so cool check out the game of
yourself link in description if you
think I'm doing bad you can play it
yourself thank you very much for
watching and I'll see you guys in next
one bye bye well you haven't tried to
Bruce emulator City after 50 million out
troops by ouch I am down just down it's
still relevant just down a bit